la seguridad de sus guardias de la
guardia suiza que cuida del papá es
bastante estricta y aquí nos tienen
detenidos aquí podemos ver otros
integrantes de la iglesia los patriarca
de la iglesia caldea en la iglesia
siriaca que estuvieron con él adentro en
una ceremonia muy conmovedora una
iglesia muy íntima llena de luz llena de
memorias que fue hablaron los dos
patriarcas el de la iglesia cátedra
aldea el de la iglesia psiquiatra y
también habló el pontífice en un mensaje
claro para su iglesia para las personas
que la representan una iglesia católica
en este país y habló obviamente del
mismo mensaje que ha venido haciendo de
la religión tiene que ser un mensaje de
paz que tiene que vivir en convivencia
que hay que hacer todo lo posible para
estar vigilantes y ayudar a la comunidad
natalina que está con ustedes justamente
ya nos decía usted un poco lo que
destaca el discurso en la catedral pero
que destaca también del mensaje inicial
atrás en la reunión con el presidente de
irak y cuéntenos un par de detalles de
la agenda que continúa para esta tarde
francisco en bagdad
bueno el mensaje que leyó esta mañana
cuando esta tarde cuando lola en la
presidencia fue bastante complejo habló
de economía habló de oportunidades habló
en un intervención internacional de
ayudar a irak y ayudar a estos países
pero sin imponer la agenda fue muy
preciso también dijo que ningún otro
país no se refirió a ellos pero no se
podría jugar con los intereses y no se
podía jugar con la gente o manipular a
la gente en bien de esos intereses y
especialmente de la guerra a bloque para
llegar a una unidad ya una paz se
necesita paciencia pero que tiene que
ser un esfuerzo de todos y un mensaje
para toda la población mira aquí y ahora
que sí que en este momento
el pontífice se retira hacia la
nunciatura apostólica donde él siempre
descansa cuando están los países al
menos eso es lo que nos han dicho porque
desde cierta manera ahí hubo comida en
los días pasados el nuncio representante
del papa ni edad yo positivo y ahí se ha
desinfectado la nunciatura sí y que
descansará para empezar el día
que también tiene una bien apretada
agenda pues les contaremos en france 24
detalles de estos días son tres los de
la visita de papá francisco a ir a
gracias catalina